okay let me take you back to our earlier
story The opposition-led rallies which
are underway across Tunisia marking the
12-year anniversary of the Jasmine
Revolution the demonstrators in the
capital of Rosetto broken through police
barriers to access the main Boulevard
these are live pictures from Tunis Mass
rallies in 2011 led to the house in your
former presidents in Ben Ali and sparked
uprisings across the Arab world today
tunisia's opposition says a paragraph by
President I said has reversed political
freedoms gained more than a decade ago
we're going to speak to Olivia Volkman
who's joining me now on the phone Alicia
tell me what's been going on at the
moment
well we've seen coastside's popularity
as steadily going down a hill because
there is serious food shortages in the
economic situation is you're beginning
to spin out of control people have asked
him to provide Solutions and he's not
done anything except lash out at the
opposition so normally you know before
the paragraph today would be very much a
festival and a very joyful occasion
um but today you're seeing a lot more
people than we have done in previous
demonstrations and there is a beginning
of um maybe not a coalition but a
coexistence between the different
political blocks who are opposing him
so we've got the the labor union the
national salvation front the Democratic
block and also the uh the the free
constitutional party led by ABIA musi
who are all demonstrating again together
today generally they're quite disparate
blocks but we have seen some political
parties the Republican Party Al John
Maria calling for a more united front
so this may be the beginning of that
unification of the different factions
and the an increasing energy to say
enough is enough
just very quickly Alicia in a couple of
sentences is there any response from
President Hayes to try to appease the
the protesters just in one sentence if
you could
and we've not seen any signs of that at
the moment there's certainly been no
police violence so for the moment things
are energetic but peaceful Elizabeth
talking to us from Tunisia Alicia thank
you very much indeed this is a breaking
story we're going to be covering it
obviously here on Al jazeer